Vsauce!
Kevin here.
The toothbrush dates back to at least the
ancient Babylonians and Egyptians who frayed
the end of a stick to scrub their teeth.
But in the 15th century the Chinese invented
something closer to the modern toothbrush
using bristles from pigs' necks attached to
a bone or bamboo handle.
Pig or Horsehair was used for toothbrushes
until nylon was invented in 1938.
Ancient toothpaste recipes have ranged from
the ashes of burnt mice heads and eggshells
to more abrasive crushed bone and oyster shell
concoctions of Greeks and Romans.
In the 1800s toothpaste was actually a powder
containing soap and chalk and it wasn't until
1890 that tubes with paste came into the picture
but unfortunately the tubes were often made
of lead which leaked into the toothpaste.
And in case you still got a cavity, Ozark
folklore held the belief that carrying the
jawbone of a donkey in your teeth and walking
backward could cure a toothache.
The Chinese have been making a form of toilet
paper since at least the 2nd century by mixing
mulberry bark, hemp and rags with water - mashed
into a pulp, then pressed and hung to dry
in the sun.
But other cultures have wiped with everything
from sticks, moss and corn cobs to pebbles
carried in a special bag or a sponge on a
stick dipped in a bucket of salt water.
When New Yorker Joseph Gayetty invented aloe-infused
sheets of manila hemp to prevent hemorrhoids
in 1857 the public scoffed at the idea because
why pay for wiping paper when they already
had old newspapers?
TP eventually caught on because of the advent
of the flush toilet and people needing a paper
that navigated plumbing — and pages from
the Sears Roebuck catalog just clogged the
pipes.
But there was a time you didn't flush urine
— you collected it to wage wars.
Urine contains saltpeter which along with
charcoal and sulfur creates gunpowder.
Outhouses in cities had trays under the seats
that were pulled out from behind and night-soil
collectors came by and emptied the contents
into a wagon where it was delivered to concrete
tanks to recover the salt peter.
During the Civil War in the US while the men
of the south were off fighting the women were
doing their part by collecting their urine
- a contribution immortalized in poems...
...What could make a Yankee soldier sadder,
Than dodging bullets fired by a pretty woman's
bladder.
And as always - thanks for watching.